peu
[Musique]
où
oh
non me rappelle moi d'avoir vu les des
gens là qui étaient plus de livres un
truc qui disait c'est bizarre moi
j'arrive à cannes les dégâts du
déménagement il en disant craindre des
troubles devant votre cas mais ça c'est
le fait que ça soit 9
avant on avait un petit deux pièces dans
une hlm à des classes traditionnelles
qui étaient pas mal
il était classique on se plaisait enfin
dès qu'on est arrivés ici on s'est dit
qu'on pourrait tout recommencer invité
quelque chose de plus pourquoi innover
innovantes ont pour mieux vendre ou pour
mieux vivre
n'est ce pas plutôt un mot alibi pour
l'architecte qui veut avant tout se
faire plaisir comme à
chanteloup-les-vignes qu'il a fait une
ville d'une conception originale où il
ya un contexte social c'est un contexte
social où il a réuni que des gens
présentant des mêmes problèmes sociaux
ensemble et bien voulait d'abord la
poésie dans sa ville qui a su poudre et
à toute culture en dix ans les gens
profiteront ne sait pas lui même s'il
sait à quel point il est on est entre la
poésie et la philosophie
mais pour nous il a fait joujou sur le
coteau pour faire une ville selon son
plaisir mais il n'est pas il en est pas
une
parce qu'il nous dit mon projet est
telle que c'est aux gens de s'adapter à
moi alors pas eu de cette affaire
lorsqu'on lui a dit que ça ne lui
plaisait pas il nous a dit mais ça plaît
à vos enfants vous vous êtes déjà
premiers mois ça plaira aussi ça ne
plaît pas ils seront obligé que ça leur
plaise
par exemple pour chanteau il voulait
reconstituer une ville romaine et en
plus il ne voulait aucun espace vert
parce que espaces verts monsieur ayo
détruirait sa notion de
ça vous voyez ça ce que vous voyez là
c'est un calcul parce que la juge des
enfants jours enfin ils veulent des
centres de données
bonjour est d'accord mais je vais vous
un petit comme elles veulent et sans
vrai regardez l'écartement des pierres
se prennent le parti s'est prise cet été
quel rythme jusqu'en bas et louise marie
que ce qu'ils pensent
quant à lui vit pas beaucoup ici alors
ivic le soir ils rentrent le soir avant
le soir des faits noir
le dimanche n'est pas là le dimanche on
essaye de partir à droite à gauche dans
mes enfants à saint jeannet pas de les
sortir actuelle de ce à quoi
c'est la grande si comme on l'a dit à
contre-pied des camps ensemble je crois
que c'est ça et catherine et surtout
pauvres aux pillards
pour les petits
regardez mois d'août s'il fait beau vous
voulez tout le monde n'y a pas de parc
y'a rien alors là ils ont connu ou faire
une bannière vice catherine pasco
il
nous rétorque souvent mais ces gens là
c'est de logement social bien sûr il y a
des gens par exemple je connais des gens
ils étaient à cinq dans une même pièce
chanteloup ils sont très contents d'être
là mais quand on leur demandait ce que
ça vous plaît ils disent non si on
trouver autre chose de mieux on
s'ennuierait du jour au lendemain
nous pensons que le logement social il
est social bien entendu par le prix qui
est inférieure notamment en termes de
loyers pour les locataires
mais il faut qu'il soit social aussi par
les conditions de vie qui doivent être
de bonne qualité qu'ils offrent à ceux
qui vont habiter leur évidemment tout ce
qu'on a fait ces dernières années de ce
point de vue là n'est pas parfait on a
fait des logements trop petits on a fait
les logements souvent mal insonorisé et
on a fait et tous ces grands ensembles
comme on dit cette architecture qui est
très monotone
je crois d'ailleurs que ce n'est pas
propre aux logements sociaux c'est
l'ensemble de la construction des 25
dernières années
[Musique]